in this video we'll talk about allergy
and this is for USMLE step one so this
is a high-heeled video stay tuned till
the end allergy is also known as type 1
hypersensitivity reaction so let's see
what can cause allergy allergies can be
caused by peanuts gluten eggs crab many
other food items like seafood it can
also be caused due to dust wool insect
sting Etc technically speaking allergy
is caused due to allergens
so a pollen grain can act like an
allergy
and there could be also genetic
predisposition that can make you more
vulnerable to show allergic responses
in hyperig syndrome for example you have
too much production of ige antibodies
which are associated with allergy so
first take home message is ige antibody
is very important for allergic responses
so another cell type that is really
important for allergic response besides
ige antibody is mast cells basophils and
obviously IG antibodies are important
for the clinical manifestation of
allergy Immunology is called allergy as
type 1 hypersensitivity reaction also
this is immediate reaction and that's
why it is known as immediate type 1
hypersensitivity
so let's see look at the overall
processes involved in allergy so let's
say there is an allergy so obviously a
dendritic cell or antigen presenting
cell would activate T cell
and the T cell would secrete certain
cytokines which would help to
differentiate themselves to th2 subtypes
th2 subtypes are the key cell types
underlying allergy
th2 subtypes for the secrets cytokines
which activates naive B cell and naive B
cell now produces ige antibodies they
differentiate into plasma cells which
produce ige antibodies so certain class
switching reaction happens as a result
of which these plasma cells secrete
selectively ige antibodies once these
ige antibodies against that allergen is
produced it binds to specific FC
receptors in the mast cells in this
condition the Mast Cell becomes
sensitized so this event is happening
after the first exposure to the allergy
so after the first exposure mass cells
become alert they become sensitized what
happens in the second exposure in the
second exposure when the allergen binds
again to this igefc receptor complex it
leads to severe Mass cell degranulation
so that means Mast Cell secretes its
granules and that leads to all the
clinical symptoms of the allergy muscle
degranulation and basophil degranulation
basophil degranulation can cause several
symptoms for example it can lead to a
different biological changes and all
these biological changes are mediated by
H1 receptors H2 receptors H3 receptors
or H4 receptors one of the key component
of these secretory granules are
histamine because we always have
antihistamines when we have allergy
right and histamine receptors are
present in different organs for example
your lungs for example your stomach
heart lungs
everywhere almost and they bind to these
histamine receptors to give rise to the
biological changes
one of the prominent feature of allergic
response is bronchoconstriction
glandular secretions mute muscle
constriction and vasodilation
treatment I mean severe form of allergy
is known as anaphylaxis which give rise
to our shock-like symptom and
anaphylactic shock can be treated with
epinephrine injection and immediately
taking the person to the emergency room
I hope this was informative if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can get more notes and flashcards in
my Facebook Channel or in Instagram page
you can
support this channel via super thanks
see you in next video